this is a suave people know these are
sloths this is an amazing amazing animal
these guys live down in South America
Central America they have a super slow
metabolism and you can see that she's
moving pretty slowly because let's see
if we can get her to eat here kind of
see if she'll eat that piece of sweet
potato how close can I get it's just an
animal that might destroy my face if she
if she climbs up to you she might think
you're a tree right climb up toward your
face that wouldn't be a good thing but
hey it's interested it's taking its hook
like claw but okay she's a little bit
more interested in what's going on back
there right so these guys live up in the
trees you see how she's hooked upside
down like that yeah that's how they move
around in the trees and they need yeah
you can get her better if you're out of
this incredible animal right here
turning around this way let me see if I
can get her to eat a piece of sweet
potato so that folks can see right did
you even decide or try to find out if
she likes sweet potato you know what we
just spooked her a little bit there we
go now we have a little bit of a better
look on her face these animals hang
upside down they can actually twist
their head almost all the way around so
they can see what's going on around them
but they're camouflage up in the tree
and the fact they move so slow keeps
them safe from predators right so they
don't have to very really fast they can
use those claws and they can use their
teeth to defend themselves but generally
speaking they're pretty mellow animals
so a a slow metabolism won't eat
vegetables sounds like my brother Neal
[Laughter]
yeah oh you had that coming completely
uninterested in I love the hooks help it
stay in the trees and exactly they hang
upside down just like she's doing and
that's how they move around may I pet
this animal or you know what we're not
gonna probably go too close because
again she does have sharp teeth and okay
even though she didn't want to eat the
sweet potato right she's a vegetarian
she's might take a bite out of you so
okay here we go you can see how
beautiful the face is and they really
are gorgeous they move Shema she moves
very gracefully very slowly she just
needs a closet hanger to live off of I
suppose that's right
that's right yeah he has to find this
exact piece of this that's a playground
in the jungle she's perfectly adapted to
live in the trees one last fun fact
about these guys because their
metabolism is so low they only poop once
a week so once a week she'll climb down
to the bottom of again my brother neo
all right I think we should probably
move on to the next stage we have next
then we have time I don't want to
frighten the sloth but maybe you could
tell us about the is this sloth live off
this thing basically this is where
that's it basically yeah so our next
animal you can't fool me this oh I
thought you thought this is the next
animal no this next oh my god yes look
at this sweetie so this is a mountain
lion kitten that's a mountain can I sit
here on the guy you can sit on the egg
why don't you squeak that Hedgehog and I
honestly I thought you said this was the
next animal I thought you thought I was
an idiot so this is a mountain lion
kitten or a cougar kitten oh my god is
the cutest animal I've ever seen no I
haven't doing this for years I have to
give a disclaimer even though she's cute
and little and she's playing with the
toy we have her on a leash this is still
a wild animal this animal could easily
kill you when she's an adult I don't
care I'm getting one but you've been
getting one and I'm going to live with
it and as it gets older and bigger I'm
going to taunt it well needless to say
you should not do that but the reason I
wanted to bring this animal on is that
the National Wildlife Federation has a
campout going on oh here taking a little
nibble of my hand right and she were
bigger she could take your whole hand
off we've got a campaign you only worry
about that we've got a campaign helped
save LA Cougars so the help save the
Cougars that live in and around San
Francisco Los Angeles organization I
thought this was to protect older women
that preyed on young men
so so what that's a check to Madonna
you know I well folks want to get
involved they can go to save LA Cougars
dot org and you can there's tons of ways
that you can help save these guys in the
wild they really need your help I
absolutely love is this a guy this is a
female check out check out the size of
her paws look at there's only a few
weeks old and again even at this size is
a few weeks she's only a few weeks old
as an adult she'll get to be you know
over a hundred pounds maybe hundred
fifty our spot yeah yeah when they're
little like that those spots give
camouflage yet when she's an adult her
eyes will no longer be blue they'll be
golden and her whole coat will be ten
that's why they call the mountain lions
we'd be worried that she's eating
through the leash right now it's pretty
tough I think what adding a jailbreak is
I think they're safe but but yeah that's
a gorgeous these guys here in LA I get
hit by cars all the time the campaign is
to build a bridge over the 101 so that
these guys will have the ability to
navigate around the landscape find mates
and knock it hit by cars so again we
really need goods that's a good cause we
want to take care of these guys so save
LA Cougars org okay and also these are
endangered as well be aware we're losing
these guys very quickly hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos
please